[Music]
things that are from the heart or things
a real passion of yours
will always i think score kind of like
higher eventually it takes too long to
make a movie you've got to absolutely
love what you're doing so any of the
genres that i have tackled is done out
of like just uh infatuation and
obsession i think most of the times when
i make films i'm trying to recapture
thrills that i had in the cinema
the comedy comes from the characters so
i guess sort of if you've got the
characters have good voices that their
kind of like strengths and weaknesses
and their
attitudes are well defined then the
comedy just comes out of that so in a
way i always think of genre films
sometimes like a trojan horse you know
where you could actually um
sneak in some bigger ideas
uh into sort of something that's
substantively a
zombie movie or a cop movie i think some
people kind of like get so frustrated at
the process like you got to keep plowing
ahead and you got to keep finding you
know get to the place where you're what
you're seeing in your head and what's on
screen are the same thing
personally i make movies
that i would like to see
so what i write and what i make is a
film that i would like to see if i were
an audience member you know i think back
at the sort of the films that like had
the most impact on me
growing up that had a
huge element of that where the sort of
the use of sound and music is sometimes
the whole show i think most of the times
when i make films i'm trying to
recapture
thrills that i had in the cinema and i
think the key thing is and this is a
difficult thing to do the key thing is
do things that you want to do not things
that you think you ought to do
i think sort of like just kind of chase
after things that you think other people
want to see rather than what you really
want to do
like
you know you could certainly have
success with that but it but
things that are from the heart or things
that are real passion of yours
will always i think score kind of like
higher eventually i think the only
screenwriting tip that i would have that
me and simon have tried to do with each
of the films
is like
absolutely
plot it all out kind of like we tried to
plot it out on one sheet of paper so we
actually made this kind of like line of
like the sort this is the act structure
and these are the 12 pubs so this is
going to happen at this point and this
is going to happen at this point so
we're very sort of methodical and
mathematical about it because it can be
a difficult thing if you're writing
without a clear idea of where you're
going to go
and in fact you know with most of the
films um certainly with sean and with
world's end a very very clear idea of
what the final scene was
um and and what that final image was
going to be
so
you know it's good to know where you're
heading so that you don't get lost and
bored along the way i don't think i've
ever done it when i've been written
something on my own
but me and joe cornish do the same thing
it's just writing out the entire story
on a flip chart because then it's just
like a road map to the entire movie this
is the flip chart that we did for hot
fuzz and we haven't actually seen this
since we kind of like wrote it and
as you'll see there's just an enormous
amount of information i think when we
started this kind of um
one of the first things we did was
pulled a lot of ideas of things that we
wanted to do and things about kind of
the
you know where we grew up and kind of
what we wanted to do plot-wise with the
film you know if you're like
sharing a
wherever you're writing whether you're
running at home or an office or whatever
or some kind of writing room it's good
to just have it in the corner of the
room so it's always there like and you
can just flip through the entire film
jeez we procrastinated a lot
no it's good
we just tried to kind of like i suppose
it was like having our own version of
simcity we tried to create our own
little world and here are lots of index
cards with loads of stuff on
if you if you go through this you can
kind of see the entire the entire film
in flip chart form
it's something like i find it easier
that if you keep writing out the story
over and over again eventually you'll
just start writing the screenplay
because
the lines will just um the lines are
just
you know a dialogue starts to drive the
plot points and then like and then you
started writing the screenplay
essentially now you i mean you're
obviously a very prolific writer how do
you approach writing do you start with
characters do you start with plot what
is your approach
i mean um
usually there's a story line i mean
certainly in in in some cases
the storyline is very clear in my head
as it was with last night in soho
with baby driver it's like i
you sort of had had a general idea but
it kept sort of just kind of like
developing
but when i'm actually writing even if i
have the story
a big part of it is just kind of like
um i would call it creative
procrastination
like
in the lead-up to writing you're just
like reading a lot like reading a lot of
research and listening to lots of stuff
that's like i like you to use music as
inspiration or you know in in the case
of soho it was a lot watching a lot of
films of the period not not horror films
or thrillers but just like dramas and
documentaries about the period right so
it's just that thing to kind of get you
in the mood and i think there's that
point where you kind of
keep sort of creatively procrastinating
until
you know your treatment document gets
so much bigger and bigger to the point
where now i'm writing the screenplay so
you know sometimes it's that thing is
that like um
people work in genre sometimes
as a delivery system to get across
like
ideas because there's a certain audience
that
might watch hot fuzz or sean is dead or
the world's end that might not watch
some like sort of like
very serious
minded uh
movies on the same topics so in a way i
always think of genre films sometimes
like a trojan horse you know where you
could actually um
sneak in some bigger ideas
uh into sort of something that's
substantively a
zombie movie or a cop movie or
you know an uh
like a robot invasion movie and the
other like sort of and that and that i
think is also
what's great about satire is that you
can kind of um
you know you can make some serious
points in something funny and i i
i've always sort of believed that that's
kind of like a really um
hopefully you know the movies that
they're
more than just
what's on the surface you know i guess
it's just like
the comedy comes from the characters so
i guess sort of if you've got
you know like
the characters have good voices and they
have
their kind of like strengths and
weaknesses and their
attitudes are well defined
then the comedy just comes out of that
you know it depends on what it is i mean
in the case of things like um
sean and the dead in the world's end
it's like taking real people
and putting them in a fantastical
situation right and sort of the comedy
in
showing the dead and world zen for
example
comes from sort of real grounded quite
naturalistic characters reacting to
something absolutely insane
and that was always the thing is that
that was the kind of the key thing with
sean and the dead when we were writing
it and also trying to get it across to
people
was that we didn't want it to be broad
we wanted it to be
real and the sort of like keep the
situation
keep the situation
serious like the zombies are like
serious and scary and could kill you and
there's the zombies aren't doing
anything funny
it's like the cat the human characters
are doing the funny stuff but then even
all of their reactions are we just tried
to ground it in
what we think we would do in that
situation or how kind of like useless we
would be in that situation
i don't know i think sort of like in
this day and age you have more
platforms to get your work out there
than when i was making when i used to
make amateur
films
and i actually was very lucky that i i
got onto one of those competitions um on
tv it was one of the first animation
films i had made but in this day and age
you know you have like youtube and vimeo
and you have a chance of like sort of if
you make a short film and it works
people all over the world could see it
but i'd say that i just think the thing
to do is try and
do something that's unique or something
that just kind of
marks you out as a little bit different
and um
you know it's a bit more difficult in
london actually in terms of i was i was
lucky in a way i didn't realize i was
lucky at the time
but um when i made my first film
when i was 20
which is a very low budget like western
it was very very silly but like one of
the own the few sort of talking points
about it was the fact that i'd done it
in somerset that it was like sort of
this kind of like almost like the cine
silly anecdotal quality too it was like
hey have you heard about this kid who
made this western in somerset like so
that straight away was actually being in
a sort of small pond was actually sort
of a good thing
because you know then coming to london
you know you're one of tens of thousands
of aspiring filmmakers in this
exploration of genre
how do you prevent uh deconstruction and
commentary
from being parody
i think if it's done with affection i
think that's the point
i think uh in the in terms of uh i mean
baby drive is a little different um but
it's got the same spirit of it in terms
of it's done with
i think it's just done with love for the
genre so in that sense i think there's a
big difference between
like when sean and the dead came out in
hot fuzz and people would use the word
spoof
we would always mean simon
bristle a little bit of that word
because
i felt like some of the spooks that were
around at the same time seemed to be
just um quite um
you know they're just uh
they it was like they hated the genre so
something like scary movie or any of
those films they seem so like they like
sort of think the entire genre is dumb
and like sort of unworthy and let's just
kind of like rip the [ __ ] out of this
kind of genre
on the flip side i hope that something
like shawn and the dead we used to call
them like a valentine is like done with
such affection
that really like we're making a film
within that genre and in that particular
one it's like what the characters are
doing is funny and what the situation is
is funny so it becomes more situationist
so i think that's the thing is they're
done with huge affection and i think
that's where it becomes something that's
like so very heartfelt
and is like
is like a serious entry in those so
that's nice to me is that like um
in terms of like when people do list
sometimes of like the best zombie films
of all time
and you know sean is somewhere in there
that's great because it's not kind of
considered it's considered like a film
within that genre it's not considered a
spoof of that genre yeah what is that
there's been a gradual
process of you know really well from
sean of the dead but hot fuzz as well of
an ironic representation of the american
action cinema yeah
and i when i see this i sort of start to
feel like there's been a gradual
you've been very slowly coming out as an
action director
and i think you know for me the action
is so spectacularly well directed in in
this film it has been i mean worlds and
the fight scenes i thought you know we
talked about it after i saw it i mean i
really loved the way you put those
together but the all of the the foot
chases the car chases in this
it's like oh you really mean it you know
you really enjoy this stuff this is this
is great and there's something very
american about that about embracing that
and just the the showmanship of that i
think even with the previous films the
british kind of trilogy they're all made
out of affection like i used to always
bristle when people would call them
send-outs because i was thinking well
they're not like send-ups because that
sending up means that you're satirizing
it which in some ways makes it seem like
you don't like it whereas like the
zombie films the cop films the sci-fi
films i love those they like i i always
saw them as valentine's and then this
one i think it was always the intention
to make something that was actually
music i mean obviously there's a
subjective twist to it with the music
but in terms of the heist and action
element is just do that kind of
you know sort of dead ahead and play
that straighter and make it more
relentless um i was wondering who do you
like within the five main leads who do
you see
most in yourself and who if you wanted
to be who would you like to be
in that like
friends i think what you end up doing is
that myself and simon put different
parts of ourselves into everybody
so like eddie marzan has that story with
the bully which is a sort of an
amalgamation of something that happened
to me and something happened to simon
like um i guess there are parts of us
and gary king but then on the flip side
patty constantine's character has that
thing where he well there's an
amalgamation there because like um
there's a thing where simon has been out
with the best friend's sister and i had
done that and then
my other friend had been out with her as
well so it created this awful like so
awkward like not a love triangle but
like a love square so just lots of
elements of different people you know
and i think sort of like
it's interesting with the kind of
characters as even when the actors come
on board kind of the first thing we did
when we rehearsed the movie is sat
around and talked about
being that age they keep mentioning in
the script there's this hot girl called
becky salt that they keep mentioning
and uh
like everybody around the table had a
different like girl at school that they
were never with
and what's funny is like the the uh
she she was somebody that i didn't it
was the name of a girl that i went to
school with except it wasn't somebody
that i fancied my friend fancied her so
when i think of the name of like a hot
girl i think of my friend going oh my
god becky's soul
there wasn't so so if she ever sees the
film she's going to think that i have a
crush on her
and i say no it's not a nick field had a
crush on you
it's a bit different when you have a
co-writer because then
then you know then it can be a bit more
formal because
you know with
larsen soho which i wrote with kristen
wilson cairns
she came on to write the screenplay with
me at a point where i had the story sort
of
kind of
pretty clear and it was all like mapped
out and
tons of research but it was a matter of
like then okay let's sit down and write
the screenplay
right so
when you have a partner they keep you
honest is basically what you're saying
if it goes both ways i mean i feel like
somebody's always got to be a good cop
and bad cop for anybody
simon pegg and he won't he he he won't
he won't be annoyed that i say this and
he cannot deny it but definitely in the
writing of like sean and hot fuzz i was
definitely good cop i was like the head
master cracking the whip
inside
it was kind of trying to sort of
negotiate down the amount of time we
spent in the right room on a daily basis
simon is an amazing writer so it kind of
all worked out but i always found it
funny that he was always
you know weedling around like hey i
might not be able to make it in until
like you know he's brilliant he's you
know
but there are things like there's one
line in the film
where i was about to tweet it
just as a joke and then i stopped myself
and i thought oh no i'll keep that
like that's another thing is don't burn
don't burn all your jokes on twitter